in the book there is this uh
first version of wework that many people
don't know about
which was green chair which was going to
be like an eco
friendly co-working space adam had two
partners on it
he had talked a landlord in brooklyn
into giving him the space
and it worked really well gothamist uh
the blog was
sort of um housed out of there and it
went so well
that the landlord bought out adam and
his partners tell that part of the story
because i think it's instructive that
this was a great moment in time
to create this very innovative idea of
you know offices as a service we look at
like one of the big
when we used to raise money for
companies the first thing you did was
like buy some servers and the next thing
you did was sign up to your lease
and then wonder if you had signed for
too much or too little
and this was a pretty innovative idea
was it not
it was and and this was coming out of
the financial crisis of
of 2008 um it was actually sort of right
in that and it
in some ways it felt like a bad moment
but in in einstein it was it was kind of
perfect
because you had all these people looking
for for different solutions you had
companies downsizing you had a lot of
freelancers
and as as the company grew as you know
yeah they had green desk for about a
year
uh oh green desk not green cherry green
yeah yeah you know different
there i mean the funny part about it is
there was also a
half a mile away a place called green
spaces that was basically doing the same
thing so there was this little kind of
boomlet of
of these companies where it was like yes
the real estate world does not
seem to be meeting the demands and
specifically the the demands of the
startup world which was
uh right now i might have two people
next year
i might have 20 or i might still have
two like i don't i don't totally know
and
and so what wework provided was you know
beyond what everyone talks about which
was
the beer keg and and the coffee and the
nice place to kind of meet
was flexibility and you could have
different offices of different sizes
um you could do a month-to-month lease
you could you just had
had a lot more adaptability to whatever
sort of your
your needs were so i think for a long
time and especially as kind of the
startup world was really getting going
again
after the financial crisis it really
served a pretty
pretty clear need for that community in
particular and
it was so profitable and valuable that
green desk that the landlord
um who owned many buildings in brooklyn
said to newman and his partners
i want to give you 500 000 each and buy
you out
and this is after one year so that i own
a hundred percent of this
so it was confirmation that this was a
brilliant idea it was working and he
said just stay the hell out of brooklyn
uh you have a non-compete to stay out of
brooklyn one of the three partners went
back to israel
was like i got my 500 but he talks the
other founder into hey let's start we
work and find another space
and start again in lower manhattan
correct
yeah and green desk uh still exists i'm
here in dumbo right now and
and it's it's still here a few blocks
away and and that landlord went and
expanded it into
half a dozen spaces in brooklyn and and
what adam and his his co-founder miguel
mckelvey sort of
said was they wanted something bigger
they wanted
they they didn't want to just stay in
brooklyn and and they also wanted to run
their own business they didn't want to
necessarily be
a partner or sort of owe this landlord
as kind of
the person who had the space so they
it was clear the idea had legs um the
tricky part was
was sort of still convincing kind of
landlords to take a risk on
on this company because it was sort of a
risky model it had existed before and
especially
in recessions which we were in at the
time
it's it's it's a potentially dangerous
model because if you can't find
people to rent your little offices out
of you're still on the hook and
and people have had gone under in the
past from this very same
sort of idea